so you want me to tell you what we do
specifically just okay we blow up bombs
I can't respect let me PC PC confuse me
after 9/11 there was a push from the
federal government for bomb squads new
Matane robots use it about one to two
times a month it gives us as officers
the ability to not approach something
that we think may contain explosives so
let's go to that video of authorities
sitting out that robot to investigate
the suspicious item it appeared to be
some sort of jacket a member of the bomb
squad moving in and obviously all ends
well I mean everyone's safe there are
466 bomb squads in the United States
that operate a robot like this here in
Sacramento the California Highway Patrol
is showing me how their robot can
perform missions controlled remotely by
fiber-optic cable or by wireless this
particular model has three cameras and a
two-way radio and an operator can
remotely control it and they climb
stairs opens doors picks up and remove
suspicious packages and blows them up
how difficult is it to drive at first
it's difficult to drive we operate in a
three-dimensional world right the
cameras are two-dimensional yeah so it
takes time for the operator you get used
to looking at the cameras how do you see
to get it out of it those easy to get a
robot in hard to get it back out as a
robot is a tool is not the main thing
that we use on a daily basis the robots
which cost about two hundred thousand
dollars each are only sold to the
military and law enforcement most u.s.
bomb squads owned and andros
manufactured by one of the largest
military contractors in the country
Northrop Grumman
I visited their headquarters in Clinton
Tennessee where they and Ezra BOTS have
built by hand repaired serviced
customized contested the products that
we make and sell are very proud of them
because they do a good thing they save
people's lives they were first built to
handle radioactive materials at the Oak
Ridge National Laboratory
by the 90s they were being used for bomb
disposal and post 9/11 the company has
broadened our line of adding more
abilities and customizations to that end
Northrop Grumman is making their robot
bigger and stronger to handle what they
see is evolving threats vehicle bombs
are a threat in the past a robot could
pick up nominally 100 pounds some of the
newer robots can pick up close to 300
pounds they've sold more than 2,000 of
these robots and with so many bomb
squads in the United States owning one
they show up in the news almost every
night back now from Dallas where police
ended the deadly siege in the city last
night by using a robot with a bomb
Dallas police turned to overseas
battlefield tactics to take out the
gunmen the Dallas incident is important
because it was the first time that a
robot was used to take the life of
someone posing a danger to the public
Northrop Gruman doesn't comment on
incidents involving its robots but what
they and those who operate them are very
clear on is that this kind of robot is
not getting the ability to think for
itself anytime soon you need vacuum
element to decide what's safe what's not
how do we do this what are the
ramifications if we take this route of
action what's going to happen
currently with the current technologies
in our robot I just don't see it being
automated with where you send it
downrange
it handles your package and comes back
and everybody's safe
you